he was one of the world's most notorious
and ruthless leaders since coming to
power in 1979 Saddam used any means
necessary to hold on to Iraq including
killing anyone who stood in his way at a
young age he was brutalized at home run
away to his uncles and quickly became a
thug for an extremist political party as
he rose through the ranks and took over
he modernized the country and ruled
through fear eventually his greed
defiance and murderous ways led him to
the gallows
today on by graphics we learn about the
life of Iraq's former President Saddam
Hussein
[Music]
on April the 28th for 1937 Saddam
Hussein was born to a peasant woman in a
mud and straw village called Al our near
to crit on the banks of the Tigris River
Saddam bore the physical marks of his
tribe on the wrist of his right hand a
tattoo of three dark blue dots most
people in this village lived in severe
poverty and life was very difficult
Saddam's father a sheep herder
disappeared before he was born then a
few months later Saddam's
twelve-year-old brother died from cancer
this sent Saddam's mother subah into a
crippling depression and she attempted
to abort her unborn baby and to kill
herself she failed and when her infant
son was born she named him
Saddam which means in Arabic the one who
confronts or the stubborn one without a
husband Samaritans have the means to
support her baby she sent Saddam to live
with her brother Khairallah to laugh a
retired Army officer and Arab
nationalists and Chris Saddam lived with
him for only three years until taffert
was imprisoned due to his part in a coup
to overthrow the pro-british government
in Iraq by this time Saddam's mother had
remarried a man named Abraham Hassan
villagers knew him as Hassan Valaya back
at his mother's home the young Saddam
endured regular beatings and
maltreatment of the hands of his
stepfather
neighbors and early friends of Saddam
recall Hassan beating him to wake him in
the morning and regularly shouting
things like you son of a dog out of one
shoe he was forbidden from going to
school and instead was made to be useful
by stealing goats and chickens for the
family if Saddam was caught stealing it
has been said he would rather poison the
animals than return them to their owners
at the age of 10 saddam heard his uncle
had been released from prison and he
fled to chris to be with him
sulfur filled the boy with dreams of
glory saying he would be a great leader
of Iraq someday he gave Saddam his first
real possession and that was a handgun
Saddam reportedly used the weapons who
threatened his primary school teachers
and he may have murdered a man when he
was not even a teenager according to the
story after the killing police showed up
at alphas house and found that armed
sleeping with the gun still worn under
his pillow under his uncle's care Salam
was finally able to go to school but he
learned much more than how to read and
how to write through the years he was
deeply influenced by
Alfa's politics and after leaving the
alkar secondary school in 1957 at the
age of twenty saddam joins the arab bath
socialist party as a low-level thug and
gunman the party was formed in syria in
1947 with the ultimate goal of unifying
the various Arab states in the Middle
East at the time it was the most radical
nationalist party in Iraq and it had
become an underground revolutionary
force when he was 22 Saddam played a
major role in the Baath parties
assassination attempts of the then Iraqi
Prime Minister Abdul Karim Kasim during
the attack on October the 7th 1959
Saddam and other assassins ambushed
Kasim scar on Baghdad's busiest street
the Prime Minister's chauffeur was
killed but the Prime Minister was spared
surviving gunshot wounds in the arm and
shoulder Saddam escaped with a bullet in
his leg the official version of the
story portrays Saddam as a hero who dug
the bullet out with a penknife another
version suggests that the plot failed
because Saddam opened fire prematurely
several of the would-be assassins they
were caught tried and executed but
Saddam was not he managed to flee to
Syria before eventually seeking refuge
in Egypt while in Egypt Saddam studied
law at the University of Cairo
Saddam returned to Iraq in 1963 after a
successful military overthrow of Kassim
government after his return Saddam was
recruited for yet another assassination
the Baath Party
suffered from infighting and a coup was
plans to overthrow the leader the plan
however was betrayed and Saddam became a
wanted man he was forced into hiding but
was caught and imprisoned in 1964 while
he was in prison he remained active in
party politics and read up on his role
models tyrants like Joseph Stalin and
Adolf Hitler in 1966 Saddam escaped
prison thanks to the help of sympathetic
prison guards afterwards he was
appointed deputy secretary of the
regional commands and became a rising
star in the barth organisation
[Music]
in 1968 another successful coup in Iraq
put Saddam's Baath Party in power and
President Ahmed Hassan al-bakr Saddam's
cousin named him deputy head of the
secret police
Saddam proved to be a ruthless but
effective politician within governments
he either eliminated or co-opted
individuals who stood in his way
eventually he clawed his way to become
the Vice President of Iraq's
Revolutionary Command Council the RCC
the core group that Helda racks baja
fist government together although not
the official president of iraq until
1979 saddam truly held the reins from
the early 1970s onwards when the Baath
Party seized control it did not enjoy
widespread support across the country
that changed after Saddam nationalized
Iraq's oil industry in the early 1970s
before the energy crisis of 1973 as a
result the nation enjoyed a boom to the
economy and the massive earnings allowed
the Baathist government to fund the
health education and Public Works
sectors and expand social programs in an
attempt to wipe out illiteracy Saddam
required all children to attend school
and made it free through high school he
also provided free hospitalization to
all Iraqis and full economic support to
the families of Iraqi soldiers such
reforms were unheard of in any other
Middle Eastern country in the years
before the iran-iraq war construction
became one of the prized occupations of
Iraq's middle class it is also important
to note that 40% of the increased
revenue from oil went to buying
armaments from Western and Soviet
suppliers that figure increased at the
onset of the war with Iran in 1979 when
Al Baqarah attempted to unite Iraq and
Syria in a move that would have left
Saddam effectively powerless
Saddam forced Alba car to resign and
long July the 16th 1979
Saddam Hussein became president of Iraq
five days later he called him assembly
of the Baath Party consisting of roughly
250 people at the meeting party
officials sat mystified as Saddam made
the announcement that he had uncovered a
plot against him and he claimed the
conspirators were in that very room an
alleged informants then read a list of
68 names out loud and each
was promptly arrested and removed every
single one of these individuals was
eventually tried and found guilty of
treason 22 of them was sentenced to
death the whole ordeal was filmed and
circulated around Iraq this was an
intentional well scripted display of
Saddam's power and a clear message of
who was in charge three months later
Saddam declared 14 people up to 13 of
the Jews part of a zionist spy ring he
made a very public carnival-like display
out of their execution by stringing them
up before a crowd of thousands in
downtown Baghdad over the next several
months Saddam had more plotters murdered
on television and he hung them up on the
city's lampposts to guard against coos
and ensure loyalty Saddam surrounded
himself with his kin putting his fellow
Klansmen in government positions he
regularly used informants and the secret
police to route out suspected
conspirators if anyone so much has made
a joke about Saddam they could have
their tongue cut out or even pay with
their life he believed it was better to
murder a person of suspicion and be
wrong than it was to not and then be
killed by them
[Music]
Sadam married his first cousin sajida
his uncle talvez daughter their five
children including two sons Uday and
Qusay as well as three daughters
rock-out Rana and Halle he took on
mistresses but did not parade them
around publicly later on when his sons
grew up he gave them high-ranking
positions within the Iraqi government
Saddam's public image was meticulously
crafted he dyed his hair black sported a
moustache and refused to wear his
reading glasses and less in private he
had a slight limp due to a slipped disc
so he was never filmed walking for more
than a few steps he was six foot tall
and his weight fluctuated from trim to
chubby but his well tailored suits were
made to disguise his protruding belly
each of his twenty palaces was kept
fully staffed with meals prepared daily
as if he were in residence to disguise
his whereabouts he moved around
frequently and used body doubles to
thwart assassination attempts his meals
delicacies like imported lobster were
first tested for radiation and then
poison his wine of choice was the
Portuguese rose eh but he never drank in
public do you maintain the conceit that
he was a strict Muslim Saddam was
particularly phobic about germs and even
top generals someone to meet him what
often ordered to strip down to their
underwear as their clothes were then
washed irons and x-rayed before they
could get dressed to see him they also
had to wash their hands in disinfectants
during his imprisonment it is said he
would try to maintain this cleanliness
by wiping his utensils and food tray
with baby wipes before eating throughout
his rule he maintains a limited world
view and possessed little knowledge of
Western culture laws and advancements in
technology he was once shocked to learn
there was no such law in the u.s. that
prevented citizens from complaining
about the president
[Music]
the same year that Saddam anointed
himself presidents of Iraq Iran's
Ayatollah Khomeini led a successful
Islamic Revolution Saddam's political
power rested in part upon the support of
Iraq's minority Sonny populist and he
worried that developments in Shiite
minority Iran could lead to a similar
uprising in Iraq in response on
September 22nd 1980 Saddam ordered Iraqi
forces to invade the oil-rich region of
Khuzestan in Iran a clear violation of
international law the conflict soon
turns into an all-out war won Saddam
foolishly expected would be over in a
matter of weeks
Saddam had no prior military experience
and he grew Slee underestimated his
enemy Iran was three times the size of
Iraq and a formidable opponent a
stalemate ensued with both sides engaged
in bloody trench warfare at the same
time ground troops were deadlocked
Saddam sunk millions of dollars into
developing nuclear weapons
in 1981 Israel took this matter
seriously believing that if Saddam had
the ability there would be no preventing
him from dropping atomic bombs on their
cities in June the Israeli Air Force
destroyed Iraq's research centre
rhetoric at least 25 pounds of enriched
uranium were reported to have been on
site the plants was near completion and
scheduled to begin operations within a
matter of months the destruction of
Iraq's nuclear plants was humiliating
and with no end in sight to the war
Saddam consulted his cabinet in the
meeting Saddam's Health Minister
suggested that he step down in order to
form a ceasefire with Iran as the story
goes Saddam
thanked him for his candor and then had
him arrested on the spot the minister's
wife pleaded with Saddam to release her
husband and he promised that he would
when he was sent home the next day he
was delivered in a black canvas body bag
cut up into tiny pieces in the closing
days of the war with Iran Saddam's
murderous ways reached new heights in
this most savage act he poisoned
thousands of civilian Kurds using
chemical gases killing upwards of 5,000
people and injuring 10,000 more the
genocide became known as the Halabja
massacre or Bloody Friday Iranian
photographer Cavor Goldstein witnessed
the gas attacks from a helicopter he
stated it was life frozen life had stops
like watching
film and suddenly it hangs on one frame
it was a new kind of death to me the
aftermath was worse victims were still
being brought in some villagers came to
our chopper they had 15 or 16 beautiful
children begging us to take them to
hospital so all the press sat there and
we were each handed a child to carry as
we took off fluid came out of my little
girl's mouth and she died in my arms one
decade after the attack at least 700
people were still being treated for
severe after-effects of this Massacre
surveys have concluded that the Kurdish
population in this region suffer from a
higher percentage of medical disorders
birth defects and various diseases
including cancers and heart disease on
August the 20th 1988 after years of
intense conflicts that left half a
million casualties on each side a
ceasefire agreement was finally reached
the eight-year war ravaged Iraq's
economy and infrastructure 1 million
Iraqi soldiers were out of work at the
end of the 1980s Saddam turned his
attention towards Iraq's wealthy
neighbor Kuwait Saddam believed that the
Kuwaitis had two hundred billion dollars
in various bank accounts around the
world and to take over of this small
country would yield him all the riches
he needed to pay back Iraq's war debt
and stabilize his country using the
justification that Kuwait was
historically a part of Iraq Saddam
ordered the invasion on August the 2nd
1990 it took only six hours for Saddam's
armies to occupy the country and we've
greatly condemned around the world a UN
Security Council resolution was promptly
passed imposing sanctions and setting a
deadline of January the 15th 1991 for
the Iraqis to leave Kuwait during the
occupation
Saddam staged a number of bizarre
televised interviews with citizens of
Kuwait in which he asked them if they
were happy with the Iraqis invasion and
of course in all these interviews they
said absolutely because they didn't have
a choice when Saddam ignored the January
the 15th deadline a coalition force
headed by US President George HW Bush
confronted Iraqi forces Saddam was no
match for America's firepower and modern
warfare technology within just six weeks
Saddam's troops were out of Kuwait a
ceasefire agreement was signs the terms
of which included rock dismantling its
germ
Chemical Weapons programs the previously
imposed economic sanctions levied
against Iraq remained in place despite
this and the fact that his military had
suffered a crushing defeat an estimated
150,000 Iraqis died Saddam claimed
victory in the conflict he called the
mother of all battles his biggest
victory in the maintains that Iraq had
actually repulsed an attack by America
and its criminal gang he said Iraq has
punched a hole in the myth of American
superiority and rubber to the nose of
the United States in the dust
during the 1990s various Shiite and
Kurdish uprisings in Iraq occurred but
the rest of the world fearing another
war did little or nothing to support
these rebellions and they were
ultimately crushed by Saddam's forces at
the same time Iraq remains under intense
international scrutiny
Saddam violated the terms of the UN's
peace deal when inspectors were sent
into Iraq they found and destroyed
stockpiles of weapons including chemical
and biological warheads and a super gun
with missiles capable of reaching Israel
the inspectors also alleged Saddam was
still at work at developing nuclear
weapons in 1993 when Iraqi forces
violated a no-fly zone imposed by the UN
the United States launched a damaging
missile attack on Baghdad further
strikes occurred in 1998 with economic
sanctions still in place in the years
following the Gulf War Saddam continued
to maintain his personal wealth and his
family's wealth through selling oil and
medical supplies meant for his people on
the black market while the citizens of
Iraq were in dire straits he built
opulent palaces and maintained his
lifestyle
[Music]
after the terrorist attacks on the US on
September the 11th 2001 president george
w bush and members of his administration
suspected Saddam's government of having
a relationship with Osama bin Laden's
al-qaeda organization they also
suspected him of possessing weapons of
mass destruction in his January 2002
State of the Union address President
Bush named Iraq part of his so-called
axis of evil along with Iran and North
Korea
later that year UN inspections of
suspected weapons sites began but a
little or no evidence that such programs
existed was actually found despite this
on March the 20th 2003 under the
pretense that Iraq did in fact have a
covert weapons program and that it was
planning attacks a us-led coalition
invaded Iraq within weeks the government
and military had been toppled and on
April the 9th 2003 Baghdad fell Saddam
however he managed to elude capture in
the months that followed an intense
search for Saddam began while in hiding
Saddam released several audio recordings
in which he denounced Iraq's invaders
and called for resistance finally on
December 13 2003 Saddam was found hiding
in a hole in the ground in a bunker near
a farmhouse in a draw near to create the
once well dressed and groomed leader
looked disheveled unshaven and
bewildered when he was arrested Saddam
was moved to eight US base in Baghdad
where he would remain until June the
30th 2004 when he was officially handed
over to the interim Iraqi government to
stand trial for crimes against humanity
with his days numbered Saddam showed no
accountability or remorse for his crimes
in 2003 when asked by Iraqi politicians
about his brutal acts Saddam calls the
halabja attack Iran's handiwork said
that Kuwait was rightfully a part of
Iraq and that the mass graves were
filled with thieves who fled the
battlefields Saddam declared that he had
been just but firm because Iraqis needed
a tough ruler during his trial Saddam
would prove to be a belligerent
defendant often boisterously challenging
the courts Authority and making bizarre
statements on November the 5th 2006
Saddam was found guilty and sentenced to
death the sentencing was appealed but
ultimately upheld by a court of appeals
on December 30th 2006 at Camp Justice an
iraqi base in baghdad
was executed he was then buried and
Allah WA his birthplace on December 31st
2006 this closed the chapter on one of
modern-day history's most tyrannical and
brutal dictators so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic if
you did there's a couple of things you
could do right now one is hit that like
button below also if you want more stuff
like this we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday so hit
that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else right now stuff from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]